i was sitting in the audience watching  people speak on stage i was always like  it has to be more complicated than this  like it can't just be what they're  saying and now having been on the other  side of this i've got this framed in my  mind which is advanced people always do  the basics and the meaning of that is  that most people who are casting stones  and saying it has to be more complicated  that aren't even doing it and the thing  is is that when you scale all scaling  really is is doing all the things you  did in the beginning of your business as  well as your before just way more of it  and that's what makes you advanced it's  not complexity it's scale